معنا من جنيف المتحدث باسم اليونيسيف جيمس
الدر سيد جيمس اذا لا شيء يشير انه لا
يؤكد انه لن تتم عمليات عسكريه في رفح
وبالتالي مما تحذرون في
اليونسف بالنسبه عمليه التحذير المهمه جدا
بعد اشهر صعبه للغايه بالنسبه للاطفال رفح
لابد ان يكون بها تقريبا
125000 لكن هناك 600 ال من الاطفال الذين
يختبئون هناك كثيرون منهم هاجروا الى هناك
هربوا الى هناك وهذا اخر
مكان بعيد لكنه يفترض ان يكون امدا من اي
قصف وبالتالي هنا هنا ك مخاوف من ان نشهد
عدد كبير من الاطفال يقتلون بسبب القصف
وهذا طبعا لا ننسى كذلك النقص والحرمان من
المياه وكذلك الغذاء
والادويه قبل قليل المكتب الاعلامي في غزه
حذر من ان هناك مجاعه في غزه وحذر بانه في
حال عدم ادخال الف شاحنه للمساعدات فان
القطاع سيعرف مجاعه حقيقيه وهذا ما حذر
منه الكثير من قاده العالم ماذا عن هذا
الوضع الانساني
ايضا نعم انت محق غزه
الان
تشهد اسوا مستويات من سوء التغذيه بالنسبه
للاطفال في مقارنه باي مكان في العالم
وهذه من صنع الانسان وبامكاننا ان نتجنبها
وهذه ليست مساله معقده كالتي كان نشهدها
في حالات تتعلق بالجفاف او اي مشاكل اخرى
بامكاننا ان نحل هذه المشكله ونتاكد ان لا
يكون هناك المزيد والمزيد من الاطفال
الذين يلقون حذفهم ان نتاكد ان لا يتم
استهداف المستشفيات والحصول على المياه
وكذلك الحصول على الغذاء كل هذه الامور كل
هذه الاحتياجات هي متاحه وهي تبعد دقائق
من هؤلاء الاطفال فقط تحتاج الى وقف
لاطلاق النار لتدخل هذه الشاحنات عبر الح
بالعوده الى الوضع في رفح هناك من يقول
انه ربما قبل بدايه عمليات عسكريه من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي سيتم اخراج المدنيين او
نقلهم الى اماكن اخرى حتى داخل القطاع هل
يتحمل الوضع الامني اولا في قطاع غزه
والوضع الميداني والانساني في غزه يتحمل
نقل كل هذا العدد من المدنيين نهيك على
عدم التزام اسرائيل في المرات السابقه
بالحديث عن اماكن
امنه نعم انت محق تماما فيما قلته هناك
مساله هناك مسالتين هناك غياب لاي منطقه
امنه وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن هذه السرديه
هي سرديه غير صحيحه السلامه تعني السلامه
من القصف ومن الناحيه القانونيه لابد ان
يتم توفير النفاد للماء وكذلك
لماوى وغداء وهذا الامر ليس صحيحا ليس
ممكنا على الارض هذا رايته بام عيني عندما
كنت في رفح وخان يونس فكره نقل الناس الى
ماكنه اخرى هذه فكره غير ممكنه لانه لا
يزال هناك قصف في مناطقه اخرى هناك دمار
لا يشبه اي دمار اخر شهدناه هذه المناطق
هي ماهوله بالسكان كل الادوات كل الاليات
تم تدميرها عندما تنقل من منطقه من غزه
الى منطقه تم تدمير فيها كل المباني ليس
هناك نفاد للماء للغذاء للادويه هذا مدمر
ومتعب بالنسبه للمشاهدين ويتخطى حتى مساله
الازعاج والتعب بالنسبه لهم موجودين على
الارض وبالتالي هناك نقص للاصحاح الاصحاح
ياتي من خلال وقف اطلاق النار
الانساني بالتالي بعد ذلك الغزيين يودون
العوده الى بيوتهم وفي الوقت الذي يتم
تدمير فيه ثلثي البيوت هنا نتساءل هل هناك
اصلا بيوت بامكانهم العوده اليها سيد جيمس
في هذه اللحظات نكلم نكلمك فيها الان في
خان يونس قوات الاحتلال دخلت مدارس العوده
احتجزت من احتجزت اخرجت الشباب فوق ال 15
سنه وابقت على النساء والاطفال في هذه
المدارس
وبالتالي عن اي امان او اماكن امنه فيما
يتعلق بكم انتم كونسيف فيما يتعلق بالمراه
والطفوله يمكن للفلسطيني في غزه ان يلجا
اليها وحتى المدارس يتم
اقتحامها ليس من الممكن انا لم اذهب الى
غزه منذ شهر ديسمبر لكن لا يزال هناك
الكثير من الاصدقاء والزملاء الذين واصل
معهم تقريبا بشكل يومي والجزيره بالطبع هي
الجهه الاعلاميه التي لديها اشجع
المراسلين على الارض وانا اتابع بشكل يومي
المستوى التعب وال الهلاك الذي اصاب
الكثير من النساء والاطفال الاشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم نفاد للمياه اذا المساله ما هو
مزعج ويصيبنا بالجنون حقيقه هذه المياه
الوقود بالنسبه لمنشات تحليه المياه
الماوى وكذلك البطانيات هي ليست بعيده هي
ليست بعيده من السهوله بمكان ان تصل الى
هؤلاء الاشخاص لكن بسبب القيود المفروضه
حقيقه هذا المكان يصعب علينا العمل فيه
لكن هذا المكان تعمل فيه اليونيسيف والون
بشكل جيد عندما يسمح لنا بان نقوم بعملنا
عندما يكون هناك مساعدات تدخل الى هذه
المنطقه عندما يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار
في هذه المناطق مجددا مجددا كل عوامل
العمل ليست متاحه بالنسبه لنا من اجل
اطفال من جن المتحدث باسم اليونيسف جيمس
الدر شكرا جزيلا لك